wir treffen uns hier in einem hotel wir
wollen das hotel nicht nennen ich fahre
hier rein ich sehe ich habe gestern
ich sehe den catering wagen und du weißt
ich liebe es geht darin von pastewka
denke ich stelle mich dorthin soll darf
ich hier parken ich muss hier sind die
drehen heute in diesem level pastewka
der raesfelder ist voller praktikanten
das fernsehen
wie ist die lage sehr gut ich befinde
mich gerade mit euch in einem hotel wo
auch pastewka gedreht wird und gestern
habe ich auch pastewka gerät in einem
hotel nebenan also ich weiß ich bin im
time warp oder irgend sowas im film ist
das wenn man so lange mit so vielen
kollegen die man so gut kennt
zusammenarbeitet ein bisschen wie
täglich grüßt das murmeltier
ja aber ich finde das ist ein großer
vorteil also mit mit pastewka mit
bastian drehe ich einfach wahnsinnig
gerne und diese die serie finde ich
super und wenn man so ein bisschen
eingespielt ist und sich mag und
respektiert hilft das in der arbeit auch
immer ziemlich das heißt man muss nicht
diese schwelle des bild schnuppern wer
ist das was will der von mir die bahn
gar nicht die gibt es nicht mehr macht
er mich mag ich ihn funktioniert hat und
gerade bei comedy ist es wahnsinnig
wichtig dass es funktioniert und dass
man so einigermaßen miteinander kann
sonst wird es nicht wirklich lustig wie
ist das an anderen sets wo das eben
gerade nicht so ist da bin ich immer
sehr nervös ich bin wenn ich das team
nicht kenne auch kollegen ich kenne sehr
unsicher und nervös erst mal und fühle
mich gar nicht so wohl ich brauche mal
so ein bisschen familienanschluss und
dass ich irgendwie ein paar leute kenne
und so das hilft ihr habt ja sogar mal
zusammen gewohnt mit
christoph maria herbst richtig hatte das
berufliche gründe so nach dem motto
willkommen und
es war wirklich reiner zufall christoph
lebte in dem haus als allererster dann
lebte bettina lamprecht eine kollegin
auch die bei pastewka mitspielt eine
zeit lang dort dann zog christoph eine
wohnung höher in diesem haus seine
wohnung wurde freilich nahm seine alte
wohnung dann zog bettina lamprecht aus
bastian pastewka zog zeitweise in die
wohnung von bettina lamprecht bastian
ist wieder ausgezogen herbst und ich
leben aber noch in dem haus es ist
zufall gewesen er hat das haus was
besonderes was besonders erfolgreiche
comedians leben nur verrückte drinnen
nein keine ahnung es
ist einfach so passiert aber ihr habt
nicht ihr seid dann auch auf dem flur
begegnet oder keine wg also wir haben
getrennte wohnungen wir können alle
unsere türen zu machen
genau aber könnt ihr euch dann abends
noch mal sehen also sagte ich habe schon
gedacht wir haben da aus diesem aus
dieser
wg in gewisser weise als dieser haus wg
entstand ja auch die idee zusammen
theater zu spielen und führte zum
männerhort den wir in berlin am kudamm
spielen das entstand im grunde genommen
dort in diesem haus diese ideen das
heißt der feierabend ist kein feierabend
bei euch sondern dahin dilemma ist dann
gegenseitig als witz büchern vor und
ich muss immer nur unsere eigenen
sendungen an und mal nein aber er
überlegt sitzt dann schon zusammen und
überlegt man das hat mir gut aber ist
das dann so ein arbeitsessen wir haben
die freiheit ist wir sind ja miteinander
befreundet also es ist dann doch eher
pizza chips viel schokolade eiscreme
trifft man braucht zum nachdenken
braucht ihr
mut du hast ja noch was neben dem stuhl
stehen eine cd euro muss ich dir jetzt
rein halten und ja das war so also doch
doch demonstrativ würde in die kamera
halten mag wärmer ist ein autor der viel
gearbeitet hat für rtl mein leben und
ich ritas welt und so weiter hat ja
gestimmt hat ein buch geschrieben hölle
all inclusive einen sehr gut gemachten
ist eine schöne urlaubslektüre bands und
ich er hat mich gebeten ja ist es
wirklich spielt auf gran canaria gibt
ein bisschen um swingerclubs jetzt hat
es gekauft ich habe das hörbuch
aufgenommen für ihn hat mich gebeten das
zu tun ich habe es gerne gemacht und ja
das gibt es jetzt im handel wie auch das
buch weil die ich kann man wirklich als
multitalent dafür zahlen nein wenn sie
also theater schauspieler autor dort
bühnenstücke bearbeitet du liest
hörbücher comedian
so wie sie jetzt reichen bald meine
finger nicht mehr aber auch nicht ja
wahnsinn weil es mir immer zu langweilig
war nur eine sache zu machen das hat
damit zu tun aber es hat auch mit
anderen dingen zu tun zum beispiel gab
es ja auch phasen wo ich sehr wenig
gearbeitet habe und wo nichts passiert
ist und wo ich dann mir damals ein
computer kaufte und gesagt habe ich
probiere mal zu schreiben ich fange mal
was an in der zeit und nutze die zeit wo
der beruf vielleicht mal nicht so läuft
nicht so funktioniert und daraus
resultiert dass aber mir war es immer zu
langweilig nur eine geschichte zu machen
ich fand das immer spannend auch zu
gucken was kann man noch machen und so
entstand das dass ich viele verschiedene
sachen mache und ich habe diesen beruf
sage ich mal von der pike auf gelernt
als statist und ich kenne auch die
zeiten von arbeitslosigkeit von ein jahr
rumsitzen kein casting kein job gar
nichts da geht die der arsch auf
grundeis da wirst du nervös und weiß
nicht wie es weitergeht und das muss man
auch aushalten lernen aber das ist nicht
einfach und man muss auch wissen dass in
diesem beruf es bergauf geht und
irgendwann auch wieder bergab geht das
ist einfach so
kommt da vielleicht eine erhöhte
aktivität her dass du sagst du was will
ich nie wieder erleben
weiß ich nicht ob das damit
zusammenhängt ich tue mich halt einfach
gerne in vielen bereichen aus und mich
interessieren viele bereiche deswegen
tue ich das jetzt wittert sorgen auch
das auch noch
regelmäßig man kann quasi fast immer
sehen jetzt ist wieder online jetzt
dreht da wahrscheinlich und jetzt genau
geht er ins bett ist ja so ganz stimmt
das nicht ich bin kein twitter dass er
jetzt sagt ich schlage mir gerade auf
oder so sondern also nicht jeden schritt
meines lebens kann man per twitter
verfolgen mut macht also schon öfter mal
gesund ja aber ich das dann auch schön
finde wenn man so ein bisschen
getwittert hat zusammen dass man sich
dann auch verabschiedet aber ich habe
das vor 23 monaten angefangen haben
bericht gelesen bei aston kutcher und
dachte was ist das denn twitter was
macht er da und sagen wir das an und da
haben wir einfach registriert und fielen
damit und ja inzwischen sind irgendwie
5000 follower und
ich habe spaß daran ich glaube die leute
haben hoffentlich auch spaß dran es ist
eine interessante form des austausches
zwischen zuschauern und künstler sage
ich mal gibt viele ideen werden da hin
und her geschoben oder auch einfach mal
ein kommentar abgegeben es wird kritik
geübt es wird gesagt das finden wir toll
das finden nicht so toll und ich kriege
das ungefiltert mit es keine redaktion
dazwischen oder so sondern es ist ja
sonst nur im theater möglich zu
empfinden wie das publikum das
eigentlich nicht mag oder nicht mag da
hast du ein applaus oder der blase und
sie schreien du
wenn du was im fernsehen machst das wird
ausgestrahlt ja am nächsten tag liste
vielleicht irgendeine kritik oder die
quote die quote die quote aber so kriege
ich auch mal ein direktes feedback du
hast ja auch videos von deiner neuen
sendung direkt lars klieve online
gestellt und es gab direkte reaktion ja
es war für mich bedingung jetzt zum
start von knigge dass ich gesagt habe
ich möchte einfach dass da vorher was
stattfindet im internet weil es einfach
wichtig ist und ich auch spannend fand
einfach mal sachen dort zu testen und
hinzustellen und das haben jetzt schon
so an die 10.000 menschen gesehen die
clips da kam sehr positive reaktion mich
jetzt total toll also du bist den
eindruck das funktioniert so ich habe
damals als wir die sendung ist
ausgedacht haben war es mir wichtig
etwas ganz neues etwas anderes zu machen
was nicht die 150 sketch show ist die
wir glaube ich alle nicht mehr sehen
wollen deswegen gibt es keinen
klassischen sketch mehr es gibt eine
klare überschrift zählen dinge die sie
nicht tun sollten wenn sie im restaurant
hinter dem hotel oder sonstwo und dann
liefern wir zehn punkten in sehr hohem
tempo hintereinander ab das ist oft nur
ein satz ein kurzes bild das da steht
und dann sind ist so eine zehner liste
diese zehn dinger in einer minute oder
einer minute 20 durch das heißt man hat
einen normalen sketch mit anna konnte
nur ohne den sketch richtig genau und
man hat auch kein stand up und kein
studio publikum und welche sendung ist
nicht belacht und all diese dinge die
wir jetzt schon so oft im fernsehen
gesehen haben die gibt es alle bei uns
nicht und das war mir wichtig weil ich
da
den anspruch habe dem zuschauer etwas
neues einfach mal anzumieten und du dir
geht auch nicht der erste video hat auch
keine es geht mir schon auf grund heißt
es ist wie vor einer premiere wie von
einer theaterpremiere man bereitet etwas
vor man steckt sehr viel arbeit rein man
dreht monatelang manche hat ja schon
vorher monate geschrieben und dann kommt
der moment wo das ausgestrahlt wird und
wo du hoffst dass es den menschen
einfach gefällt und du den richtigen
riecher hattest und gesagt hast das
könnte ihnen gefallen das weiß man nie
100 prozent und es hängt ja heute an so
vielen faktoren ab eine sendung
funktioniert oder nicht es hängt mit der
programmierung also dem sendeplatz
zusammen
und und und und und was läuft dagegen
was ist das gegenprogramm und es ist ja
heute nicht so einfach fernsehen zu
machen und aber ich drücke mir die
daumen ich bin ja da fast alleine in
diesem format es gibt kein richtiges
ensemble oder so und die leute im
hintergrund gesehen wird von nina hagen
oder am strand ja also ich muß daß ich
trage das singen wir sozusagen alleine
das heißt wenn das nicht klappt dann
bist du schuld bin ich schuld ja ich
finde aber das war auch immer wichtig
wer immer auf der schauspielschule hat
man auch immer gesagt man muss auch
fehler machen dürfen oder etwas falsch
machen denn oder falsch liegen wobei ich
nicht glaube dass ich falsch liege ich
glaube an dieses format ich glaube dass
das sehr lustig ist und dass das
funktioniert gut dann wünsche ich dir ja
schon mal gut holz ich weiß nicht runter
sehr schön vielen dank sehr gerne